MAY: Hi, guys.
I'm May.
This is Alvin, Jimmy, and Tyler.
So our group, we wanted
to do [INAUDIBLE]..
And it's kind of like--
our plan was to make
it more arcade style.
So you have levels and you
go from one game to another.
But because of time
constraints, we
ended up making four
separate games here.
And we will show
you the first ones--
ALVIN: And [INAUDIBLE] games.
So we decided to
try out [INAUDIBLE]..
MAY: So the games are made
with [INAUDIBLE] of putting it
into the Kinect.
[INAUDIBLE] chance
with the Kinect.
So [INAUDIBLE] go
on the keyboard.
ALVIN: [? So ?] this
game, "Chicken Run."
You have to make it across
obstacles [INAUDIBLE]
in between the obstacles
like arrows and [INAUDIBLE]..
So yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
MAY: [INAUDIBLE] are--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
ALVIN: [INAUDIBLE] please.
[INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
MAY: So far, this game.
It was [INAUDIBLE] that had
to be the waiter bringing food
to the customer.
We couldn't find a
way faster [INAUDIBLE]
that's like flying chickens.
Oh no.
So our games surround
[INAUDIBLE] restaurant team.
So for "Catch Catch," this has
no special graphics because we
didn't really have time.
And this also turned out to be
like a burger stacking game.
And the idea is that, if
while you're playing--
[LAUGHTER]
So the idea is the two
players are fighting for--
What happens is, if one
player has a higher one,
the other player has a higher
chance to get the burger.
[APPLAUSE]
And then there's "Chef Dash."
JIMMY: This is "Chef Dash."
You control two different chefs,
one in white and one in black.
So you have certain
orders in the top left
and you have to fulfill
those through the window.
So if I want to make pizza,
I take the pizza over here
and start cooking
it in the oven.
But I need to put a
plate on the window.
And then once the
pizza is done, you
should hear a beep beep beep.
[BEEPING]
Like that.
[CROWD OOH]
[BEEPING]
And so then you can take
that out of the oven
and then put it in the window.
And it removes it
from the order.
You also get tips.
So we have steak and
pizza and then also soda.
The soda, you
don't have to cook.
So you get more--
[LAUGHTER]
You have to put the--
[BEEPING]
So then there's some [INAUDIBLE]
black for the Chef Black, white
for the Chef White.
And you get five tips
for soda since you
don't have to cook it.
And then steak and
pizza you get 10.
So like--
ALVIN: First to 100 tips wins.
JIMMY: Yeah.
First to 100 tips wins.
It can get really
hectic if you're
putting a whole bunch of things
in and trying to get orders.
Like I was playing earlier
and me and my friend
both tried to put an
order in at the same time
for the same thing.
Like there was one soda order.
And I barely put
it in before him.
So he didn't get the tips and
they just sat there in limbo.
It was just fun.
Yes.
The first one to 100 tips wins.
It would take a while to finish
but we can go to the next game.
MAY: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
I think this game will be
really more fun on the Kinect.
JIMMY: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ALVIN: [INAUDIBLE]
control the knife.
[INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
It sort of gets harder.
There's sort of a [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] chopped [INAUDIBLE]
within the food itself,
it won't count.
So for example, you
see this broccoli.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[APPLAUSE]
MAY: That's the
idea of the game.
So our [INAUDIBLE] wanted
to [INAUDIBLE] arena
and then you could do a
whole telling out at the end.
But yeah.
For now, it's like just
four mini-games separated.
Any questions?
Any
JIMMY: Do you have
any questions?
All right.
[APPLAUSE]